as president Trump delivered a State of
the Union address last night the visuals
became a public relations nightmare for
petulant grumpy Democrats here are some
of the things Democratic lawmakers
signaled that they didn't like we
proudly stand for the national anthem
the motto is In God We Trust we enacted
the biggest tax cuts and reforms in
American history african-american
unemployment stands at the lowest rate
ever recorded
giving our veterans choice in their
health care decisions
let's bring in Republican pollster
public opinion guru Frank Luntz he joins
us from West Virginia all right Frank
the trigger words I'm sorry I was
screaming laughing when things like In
God We Trust and then they Pan the crowd
at the State of the Union the Democrats
are all sitting on their hands what
triggered them the most and what drove
them right over the edge well they
didn't want to hear any success so every
time that Donald Trump pointed to a
specific statistic a fact about how
things had changed in the last 12 months
you saw no reaction from the Democrats
second is that anytime that he suggested
that he was going to reach across the
aisle and find some sort of
bipartisanship they wanted no part of it
and third it goes back to the promises
that he made and the fact that he is
attempting to keep them that and I think
it's a tragedy quite frankly that the
Democrats don't realize that with Donald
Trump success America succeeds
Laure a lot of people criticize the
Republicans under the Obama
administration that they wanted him to
fail and yet now it looks like and I
think this is a tragedy for the country
that too many congressional Democrats
want Trump to fail so they can take over
the White House but what does that do to
the country that's a real problem what
was amazing is on the immigrant
an issue you had Trump going from
800,000 getting amnesty Frank to 1.8
million getting amnesty and he said look
people aren't going to get everything
they want
that's compromise I'm willing to
compromise let's get this done together
it's like crickets tumbleweeds were
blowing through the Democrats section
well this is something that the
Republicans have to realize that even
and I'm in West Virginia right now and
the gentleman standing behind me there
the reason why Donald Trump maintains
his popularity and why he did so well
last night they feel listened to they
feel heard and a lot of Americans felt
left out until Election Day 2016 on
immigration the public has to understand
that it doesn't look like the Democrats
themselves are ready to compromise and
if you don't get this legislation that
provides border security as well as a
solution for daca if it doesn't happen
it won't because won't be because of
Donald Trump it will be because of
congressional Democrats if Frank I
thought you needed bodyguards for a
second those guy want those guys to
travel with me I'll travel with it that
they look pretty they look pretty
stressed out I love it oh I guess none
the question or any of these guys
packing this guy right here he's packing
all right okay good okay that will leave
it there Frank Luntz thanks so much
we'll be right back stay right there